let's get reaction to this we can talk
now to mark alter wheel a lecturer in
near eastern archaeology at University
College London are very good afternoon
to you what's your reaction to these
reports obviously is very distressing
this kind of reports if it turns out to
be true of course we don't quite know
what has happened yet but if this is in
fact any kind of destruction attack on
nimrood it's a very distressing kind of
information because this site's
importance it certainly for the region
and for the country of Iraq well tell us
a little bit more about its importance
it's being talked about in terms of
being one of the most historic sites in
Iraq tell us why it's so special yeah
yeah it was a the first capital of the
what's called the neo-assyrian empire
which start around ninth century BC
surround 800s bc it was the first
capital of a series of capitals and
later empires that began this region and
eventually leads to the rise of Islam in
fact so it's one of these really
important cultural centers it's very
unique lots of unique finds on terms of
the things like ivories jewelry's the
Queen's tombs were found there this huge
stash of precious items gold precious
objects were found at this site it's a
very unique site nothing really is like
it and then your East actually well yes
and how many of the original artifacts
are still there because some have been
moved to safety haven't they I think
there's some in the British Museum as
well as in museums in Baghdad and there
are also copies there on site aren't
there so how much of what is is in the
city is genuine actually there are still
a number of genuine objects on the sites
the northwest Palace one of the
important structures on the site which I
suspect if they are bulldozing that
would be one of the sites they are
bulldozing has a lot of original reliefs
on it I was there a number of years ago
and I saw them so if they are bulldozing
these things they'll be damaging a lot
of very unique objects these specific
relief from which are in the British
Museum and tell us a little bit about
the Assyrian Empire which of course this
was at the center of at the time I mean
it had huge power didn't it an extend
give us a sense of its its place in
history
yeah the Assyrian Empire was one of the
first territorial empires that conquered
much of this region so it incorporated
for instance modern day Israel
modern-day Lebanon parts of Turkey Iran
all of Iraq and Syria as well so it's an
extensive territorial empire with
tremendous amount of wealth a lot of
that wealth was stored at nimrood so
when it was sacked a lot of that some of
that wealth was was looted by the people
who were sacking the city in the ancient
past but a lot of its still there so
these reliefs these ivories these jewels
that were found most of which are now
safely in places like Baghdad but also
in here in the British Museum and other
places around the world but the reliefs
a lot of them were still left on site
there was just too many relief to bring
back so these reliefs are most likely to
be damaged by any kind of bulldozers or
activities on the site and some are can
comparing this assault because also
we've seen destruction in Mosul as well
haven't we with the talibans destruction
of the Bamiyan Buddhas in 2001 I mean
it's not the first time that during a
war artifacts like this and historical
sites suffer yes but this is a bit
different I think this is a really
concerted effort by is to really wipe
out the ancient past of Iraq
specifically but also by extension in
the region essentially to reconstitute a
new identity for the region in this area
that their governing so I think it's a
very concerted effort to destroy the
ancient past we're seeing a pattern of
destruction of the Islamic past the
ancient past so all these things are
being destroyed one by one so it's a
concerted effort unlike other conflicts
where they tend to be sometimes victims
of the sort of crossfire between warring
sides this is very much a different kind
of pattern I think and clearly the
preservation of Iraq's heritage
primarily of importance the Iraqi people
but it's something that you believe I
imagine the whole world should care
about absolutely yeah this is a very
unique contribution to our history
certainly many things that were invented
in Mesopotamia what is today Iraq have
come down to us so the society that we
see here today always very much to what
was developed in this region so I think
preserving this particular site but also
by extension the region is very
important
if we are to understand our own past our
own current history in fact well mark
Alta will are very interesting to get
your thoughts thanks so much for talking
to us here today Thank you Thank You
time